hey today we're going to go golfing but
I can't go like this because I look like
an idiot
there we go now go acting huh acting I
take an action and then ongoing attempt
to broaden my horizons and experience
all aspects of life I'm genuinely going
to try to play golf to the best of my
abilities today I don't have club so you
rent them there and we're not going to a
high-end area we're not going to a
high-end area thank God
they're going to a medium to low end
area are certain severe is our course
golf course are going to a golf course
of course
it's nine holes all of our poorest rural
country Georgia part three but you
obviously know what that means for the
total now oh my god
oh my god east side of LA is dangerous
our three means that most people it
takes them three ten to get it as a
whole I'm going to say my scores in the
b75 for you that's my prediction I'm
going to try I already as flooding this
outfit written series not awesome and
practice the Marcos sport
wow wow wow wow wow wow wow
my family okay here you go first swing
oh oh look at that form definitely
taking practice swings oh that doesn't
count you never touched the ball doesn't
count you didn't hit it oh no really
athletic first putt attempt uh close oh
my god this is four over five no I'm
good quadruple bogey seven times nine is
what sort well that was good I think
where'd it go Oh No
we already lost one ball we can't lose
that one be careful yeah good build
Mickelson or Nicholson Jack Nicholson
hey Johnny oh my god what a green Jo nd
yeah look at your hair just going crazy
on my balls Oh
so Wendy yeah something critical what's
the win than it did it captain hey
that's actually pretty good called a
worm burner worm burner it goes along
the we can't buy the lamb is a worm
burner might be a slur I was like a
taffy swing - yeah oh man all right hmm
I just wasn't feeling to others of my
disappointment Oh got a date it's the
way optimistic oh look at that
bounce did this thing zoom very close
Oh a bogey well that's man we're really
holding people up yeah that's that with
that no hold it
seven of your wool shirt hold up
oh for birdie
holy [ __ ] haha I have a part three on
this hole and broke through that nine
Hey we're celebrating sure this is what
emotionally strong Chris and death is
right where the glory hole the final
hole at the Gulf term for the final hole
involved in okay after the eighth hole
grace is that for eh oh furgus at 51 I
need to win by three strokes on the
style home you can do it Jennifer's not
ever because I didn't know it soon
you're going to lose and you never
disappoint it well in an ungrammatical
oozing great fish before we filmed ever
you forgot that we're into something
beyond excited exam four
before that me he went oh my god that's
what very impressive oh okay and again
very subtle very modest very humble very
gracious so I ended with 57 grace in it
with 52 whoa being a five stroke doesn't
matter I won yeah
like this personal